Talvez o voluntariado
seja só um monte de tretas.
Todos nós sabemos que a história do apoio
ao desenvolvimento e do apoio humanitário
não é necessariamente uma história feliz.
Basta pensarmos no exemplo do Haiti
e do terramoto que aconteceu em 2010.
Eu estava no
Forum Económico Mundial de Davos
e ouvi o Bill Clinton a dizer um discurso
com o intuito de angariar dinheiro
para ajudar as pessoas do Haiti.
A verdade é que, durante aquele período,
11 biliões de dólares foram angariados.
E depois do terramoto,
ONGs e voluntários de todo o mundo
foram em socorro das pessoas do Haiti.
Mas a dura e negra realidade de tudo isto
é que, apesar de tudo isto, um ano depois,
um milhão de pessoas
ainda viviam em tendas,
uma crise de cólera matou
mais de 2500 pessoas,
e apenas 5% dos destroços do terramoto
tinham sido removidos.
Daqueles 11 biliões de dólares.
que foram angariados.
10% foram investidos na economia do Haiti.
Exemplos como este foram manchando
a bandeira do voluntariado,
foram manchando este ideal humanista
de que o ser humano pode ser
um ser realmente altruísta.
E aos poucos e poucos fomos perdendo
a confiança no voluntariado.
Isso reflete-se.
De acordo com um inquérito
ao trabalho voluntário
do Instituto Nacional de Estatística,
em 2012, a taxa de voluntariado
do nosso país foi 11,5%
comparando com uma média europeia de 24%.
Quando falo de voluntariado,
não falo apenas do voluntariado
que é feito através de organizações,
mas do voluntariado
que fazemos informalmente
para pessoas do nosso bairro,
como dar explicações.
Um em cada dez, em Portugal,
fez voluntariado.
Então, é urgente nós questionarmos:
Será que o voluntariado realmente importa?
E a resposta a esta pergunta
não é simples.
Talvez o voluntariado
não acrescente valor.
Talvez o voluntariado seja só
um conjunto de ações infantis, ingénuas,
embora bem intencionadas,
de quem pensa que consegue mudar
o mundo com pequenas ações
que não são eficazes a longo prazo.
Talvez o voluntariado gere desemprego
porque leva as pessoas
a trabalhar de graça.
Talvez o voluntariado seja só feito
para fazer os voluntários
sentirem-se melhor.
E mesmo que seja importante,
talvez seja só para alguns,
para os jovens e para os idosos.
Esses que têm tempo
e que vão ganhando créditos.
Eu sou voluntário desde os 16 anos,
e acredito que o voluntariado
não tem que ser nada disto.
Ao longo da minha vida,
enquanto voluntário,
eu participei do Projeto Transformers
fui um dos fundadores
do Projeto Transformers,
um projeto que usa o poder das artes,
do desporto e do hip-hop
para mobilizar a nossa juventude,
em Portugal
e torná-la socialmente mais envolvida.
Foi aí, enquanto voluntário,
que corri a selva amazónica
que estive nas favelas brasileiras,
que estive nas cidades do Zimbabué
em imensos projetos
de voluntariado diferentes.
Como já diziam na outra Talk,
não sou solteiro,
tenho uma paixão enorme pelo voluntariado.
Mas também sou economista.
Sou economista desde os 21 anos
e, desde essa altura, que também tenho
este lado muito racional e muito frio
de procurar quantificar,
de procurar medir,
de encontrar evidência estatística
que justifique o investimento
dos escassos recursos que temos.
No fundo, a minha vida ultimamente
tem sido à base dessas duas coisas.
Essa ação de ser voluntário
e esse esforço por entender
se o voluntariado realmente vale a pena.
E há sete coisas que gostava de vos dizer
sobre o voluntariado
que talvez não saibam.
A primeira é que o voluntariado
realmente gera valor económico,
e que esse valor económico
é quantificável.
A ideia que não é
por um trabalho não ser remunerado
que não gera valor.
Como é nós fazemos isto?
Os economistas têm uma forma.
Nós vamos ver o equivalente
no mercado de trabalho,
como é que uma hora
do trabalho do voluntário
seria remunerada no mercado de trabalho,
e conseguimos atribuir um valor
e quantificar o valor económico
do voluntariado.
Nós fizemos isso aos 1800 jovens,
fizemos um estudo,
em que se analisava isso
aos 1800 jovens do Projeto Transformers.
Conseguimos estimar que,
nos últimos 12 meses,
eles fizeram mais de 68 000 horas
de voluntariado
que geraram mais de 180 000 euros
de valor económico.
O que eu acho fantástico,
no meio disto tudo,
é que foram miúdos como estes,
miúdos entre os 11 e os 16,
muitos deles nem sequer recebem mesada.
que injetaram 180 000 euros
de valor económico na nossa economia.
Se isto não é uma ferramenta
de participação poderosa,
o que é que é?
Mas o voluntariado
vai mais para além disso.
O voluntariado também pode gerar impacto.
A minha própria vida é testemunho disso.
Eu, aos 16 anos, decidi tomar
uma decisão crucial na minha vida.
Eu fazia natação desde os 4 anos,
e, aos 16, decidi que bom, bom,
era seguir um sonho de infância
e ir para a rua aprender "breakdance"
com amigos meus.
Tudo aquilo que eu sei, hoje,
— ou 90% —
foi-me ensinado por amigos meus
que se voluntariaram para me ensinar.
Agora, imaginem um miúdo
que tem falta de confiança em si próprio,
imaginem um miúdo que não se sente bem,
tem receio de se expor,
imaginem o impacto para este miúdo,
de aprender algo como isto.
(Música de "breakdance")
(Aplausos)
Vocês não fazem ideia de quantas vezes
nós ensaiámos isto.
(Risos)
Mas não é só na transformação individual
que o voluntariado tem impacto.
O voluntariado também tem impacto
neste ponto de vista
da transformação coletiva.
O melhor exemplo que vos posso dar
é o da imunização contra a poliomielite.
Em meados do século XX,
a poliomielite, todos os anos, paralisava
centenas de milhares de pessoas.
E hoje em dia, a taxa de incidência do vírus
desceu mais de 99%.
Isso foi possível, não apenas
porque na década de 50
foi descoberta uma vacina,
mas também porque
mais de 10 milhões de voluntários
se mobilizaram, em todo o mundo,
para vacinar aquela gente toda.
Isso é um legado que fica
algo que não se esquece.
Mas há aqui outros mitos sobre o voluntariado.
Aqui há tempos, estávamos a fazer
um estudo de impacto
para o Projeto Transformers,
de que já vos falei,
e falei com uma pessoa muito minha amiga
que pôs um comentário no Facebook, a dizer
assim em letras grandes e gordas:
"Dói-me o voluntariado,
quando há tanta gente sem emprego".
Caiu-me o coração ali.
Se calhar, tem razão,
é uma questão legítima.
Muitas pessoas estão a trabalhar de graça.
se calhar estão a substituir
postos de trabalho
que poderiam estar a ser remunerados.
Mas isto, ao que parece, é um mito mesmo.
Se nós olharmos
— o lado economista —
para os dados dos 27 países
da União Europeia
— na União Europeia há 27 —
podemos ver que os países
com as menores taxas de desemprego,
aqueles a verde,
são também aqueles que têm
maiores taxas de voluntariado.
Embora a correlação negativa
não implique relações de causalidade,
este gráfico é indicativo, pelo menos
desta ideia de que o voluntariado
e o trabalho remunerado
não são mutuamente exclusivos,
eles antes complementam-se
e precisam um do outro.
E nós até podemos ver que,
em vários aspetos de desenvolvimento,
existe uma correlação
entre a taxa de voluntariaso
e o desenvolvimento de um país.
E há aqui este quarto ponto
— outro mito —
que há quem diga que os voluntários
sentem-se bem por fazer voluntariado.
É totalmente verdade.
Porque é que nós não havíamos
de nos sentir bem
fazendo uma coisa que faz
as outras pessoas sentirem-se melhor?
Ainda há este ponto de que o voluntariado
se calhar, também não é para todos.
Eu acredito que o voluntariado
é para todos.
porque todos temos algo a contribuir
e todos, sem exceção, precisamos
de ajuda, de alguma forma.
Havia miúdos, no Transformers,
tão novos como 12 anos,
a fazer voluntariado,
a dar explicações aos colegas,
e eles a melhorarem as notas
e pessoas com carreiras
completamente estabelecidas,
que são voluntários no projeto
e conseguem conciliar as coisas.
O voluntariado é realmente para todos.
Mas agora não intepretem isto
como "todo o trabalho voluntário é bom".
Porque isso não é verdade.
Acho que é muito importante
nós termos consciência disso.
Nem todos nós podemos fazer
qualquer tipo de trabalho voluntário.
Eu encontro na minha geração
imensos jovens
que têm um pouco esta missão de vida,
de ir para um país distante em África
ou no sudoeste asiático
fazer uma missão
de voluntariado internacional.
Aquilo que acaba por acontecer,
pegando no exemplo do Camboja,
atualmente nos EUA há imensos alunos
de universidades americanas
que, para preencher
os créditos da faculdade,
vão para o Camboja fazer
voluntariado em orfanatos.
Aquilo que tem acontecido,
é que não só os miúdos desses orfanatos
acabam por não criar relações estáveis
porque os voluntários
estão sempre a mudar,
como isso cria um incentivo para gestores
corruptos de alguns orfanatos,
manterem os blocos sujos e feios
porque repararam que os voluntários
tendiam a dar tempo, dinheiro e recursos
aos orfanatos que tinham pior aspeto.
Portanto, isto pega naquela ideia
de que o voluntariado não é simples,
nem fácil, é algo complexo e desafiador,
que exige uma paixão para nós irmos
à procura das reais causas dos problemas.
uma paixão enorme por aprendermos,
Por fim, aquilo que acaba
por me trazer aqui hoje,
não é dar-vos uma lição moralista
ou um discurso paternalista.
sobre como é que cada um
deve aplicar o seu tempo
mas é, antes, uma partilha muito honesta
de porque é que, pelo menos para mim,
o trabalho voluntário é importante.
Nós vivemos numa época em que
conceitos como a solidariedade
e como o voluntariado
perderam tanto significado.
perderam tanto significado
pelo seu uso banalizado,
pelo uso corrente,
pelo uso descontextualizado
que às vezes chegam a ter
conotações negativas.
Eu acredito que nós temos que devolver
a força a estes conceitos.
porque, se não for pelo pragmatismo
dos números que vos mostrei antes,
seja pelo voluntariado ser talvez
essa declaração suprema
da dignidade humana,
da dignidade enquanto escolha
de onde queremos gastar o nosso tempo.
Se tornarmos cada ação nossa
refém de uma transação,
então nós perdemos a capacidade
de sermos seres livres
de sermos seres autodeterminados.
Dizem que a nossa geração
é uma geração perdida de causas
e que é por estarmos perdidos de causas
que muitos jovens escolhem alistar-se
nas fileiras do estado islâmico
em busca dessa causa por que dar a vida.
Eu acredito que nós
não perdemos as causas,
as causas é que nos perderam.
Estão mesmo aqui à nossa espera
à espera que um voluntário
lhes dê a importância, o significado
e a materialização que essa causa merece.
Se nós queremos fazer todos parte
da construção de um mundo
radicalmente mais fixe,
então não nos podemos alienar
dessa magnífica e desafiadora jornada
que é ser voluntário por uma causa
pela qual a nossa vida valha a pena.
Obrigado.
(Aplausos)